monsieur le ministre ma question porte
sur les résultats de la délinquance
publiés par votre ministère en premier
lieu je voudrais rendre hommage aux
forces de l'or alors dévouement et je
crois pouvoir associer l'ensemble de mes
collègues assis sur ses bancs oui les
atteintes aux biens et les
manifestations baissé et c'est une bonne
chose même si on ignore la part du
télétravail et du confinement mais oui
les atteintes aux personnes ont augmenté
et c'est le plus douloureux cela touche
à l'intégrité corporelle des personnes
peut-être d'ailleurs certaines d'entre
elles ont-elles entendu avant d'être
agressé calmez vous tout va bien se
passer
monsieur le ministre comment expliquez
vous cette flambée des agressions
physiques dans notre pays
on vous répondre la foire aux lettons
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur gérald
darmanin
merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice boyer dans votre
département des bouches du rhône en
effet c'est -13 5% de baisse d'atteinte
pour les biens et une augmentation de 2
8% de violences contre les personnes
c'est les chiffres développables
j'aurais fait de police avant-hier je
sais que vous avez pris connaissance
d'ailleurs le maire du 9e et 10e secteur
et l'air que vous connaissez bien
monsieur royer perreaut maire de secteur
dans le secteur de monsieur tessier a
dit dans la presse hier qu'il soutenait
le président de la république vu
notamment les moyens très importants
camille le gouvernement sur la question
de la sécurité dans une île que vous
connaissez bien
c'est par exemple madame 40 2 %
d'augmentation de saisies de drogue
notamment deux mille personnes c'est à
dire 100 % de plus d'augmentation
d'interpellations pour les personnes qui
sont trafiquants dans la ville de
marseille et 147 % d'augmentation
d'avoir 120 médiateur par ailleurs pour
l'agent de prévention que porte nadia et
madame martine vassal qui est je crois
un secrétaire départemental et l'air l'a
souligné avec le maire ps de marseille
ce qui prouve sans doute que ce que nous
faisons est saluée par les acteurs de
terrain enfin comme j'imagine que vous
avez du temps madame pour pouvoir
compléter j'imagine votre question
j'aurais vous faire une citation
je n'adhère pas au discours de l air qui
décrit une france qui n'est pas tout à
fait la mienne une france nostalgique
retrouviez sur elle-même notre pays
notre pays a plus de forces qu'on le
croit j'ai trouvé que ma formation
politique dont je suis membre a dérivé
c'est eric woerth que je vous demande de
relire
peut-être
peut-être madame
il est le président de la commission des
finances de l'opposition
et c'est un homme de bien permettez vous
monsieur retailleau de voir qu'il ya des
gens qui préfèrent la france aux
combinaisons et partisane
[Applaudissements]
je croyais poser ma question au ministre
des français pas un chef de parti en
pleine campagne électorale
nous sommes ici au sénat nous sommes la
représentation nationale eh oui pendant
cinq ans vous avez laissé ensauvagé la
france chez vous citez des données qui
ne figure pas dans télé loisirs mais sur
le site du ministère de l'intérieur les
français victimes n'ont pas un sentiment
d'insécurité ressenti dans leur chair
ces agressions physiques + 18 % en cinq
ans de coups et blessures +60 consent
des risques plus 38% d'agression
sexuelle multiplié par trois en trois
ans les agressions envers les élus
chaque heure un gendarme et un policier
blessé de plus la cour des comptes a
démontré qu'il y avait moins de
policiers sur le terrain et une chute
dans le taux d'élucidation aussi
monsieur le ministre c'est bien triste
de constater que quand on pose une
question on a ce type de réponse
aujourd'hui les français mérite mieux
que ses réponses électoralistes ils
méritent ils méritent des résultats ils
méritent ils ne méritent pas la comtesse
la condescendance le mépris voire le
sexisme dont vous faites preuve on ne
peut masquer le triste bilan qui est le
vôtre en matière de sécurité que les
l'angle mort du quinquennat par ce type
de réponse les français attendent des
résultats vous avez parlé des moyens
maintenant il fallait des actes les
actes ne sont pas au rendez vous pour
les agressions physiques monsieur le
ministre ne vous en déplaise et ce sont
les chiffres de votre ministère qui le
pauvre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]